die korona zahlen in deutschland steigen
dramatisch und genau dort wo eigentlich
sonst bayerische bergwerk in chile
herrscht sind die zahlen dramatisch
gestiegen
im berchtesgadener land und genau dort
wollen wir jetzt hinsehen unser reporter
kelkheim ist vor ort karl gibt es
irgendwelche erkenntnisse darüber wie im
berchtesgadener land in dieser
traumkulisse mit viel abstand und viel
platz die zahlen sich so dramatisch
entwickeln konnten
man muss es ganz einfach sagen das weiß
hier tatsächlich niemand es kann uns
niemand sagen warum diese zahlen hier so
explodiert sind auf 252 der krisenstab
der stadt stellt der tagt hier aktuell
da ist jetzt auch noch nichts da draußen
gedrungen fest steht am wochenende gab
es in freilassing einen größeren
polizeieinsatz in einer shisha bar dort
feierten 100 menschen die polizei löste
das dann auf nach unseren informationen
soll der betreiber der shisha bei schon
des öfteren aufgefallen sein
ihn erwartet jetzt ein saftiges bußgeld
bayern ist ja bekannt für seine strengen
kroner regeln also da hat er ist heute
eine bundesweite masken pflicht ab einem
wert von 35 gefordert was passiert jetzt
im landkreis berchtesgadener land genau
also wenn man hier durch berchtesgaden
geht wo ich jetzt hier gerade inmitten
der ist bis heute stehe dann hat man das
gefühl dass es die cisco roma virus gar
nicht gibt
die menschen tragen keine maske aber was
wir eben kurz was sich kurz vorher
erfahren habe ist dass markus söder
seine gesundheitsministerin melanie huml
angewiesen hat hier ein ausführliches
maßnahmenpaket für den landkreis
berchtesgaden zu entwickeln das einem
lockdown gleich kommen soll
denn die zahlen sind hier stark
explodiert und ich konnte mit einer
sprecherin des tourismusverbandes hier
sprechen die ihm dann gesagt haben ja
jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen hat man
schon gemerkt
die stornierungen der gäste die gegen
jetzt im rasant nach oben
gerade die leute die jetzt hier
kurzfristig urlaub machen
da merkt man es sehr sehr stark dass sie
jetzt ihren urlaub stornieren ansonsten
habe ich jetzt hier aus meiner
heimatstadt dortmund ein ehepaar
getroffen die jetzt die urlaub machen
sie sind immer eine woche im herbst
dauern zwei wochen im sommer der mann
wollte erst nicht fahren aber auf
drängen der frau hatte danach gegeben
die haben jetzt diese inzidenz aldi
schreckte jetzt nicht so sehr ab die
tragen eine maske und hoffen dann dass
ich jetzt noch mal
ihren urlaub verbringen können
ja berchtesgaden eine region für urlaub
was bedeutet das was könnte das für
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen für die
ganze region haben ja wie gesagt ich
habe ja eben schon mal gesagt dass ich
hier mit tourismus mit dem
tourismusverband gesprochen habe das ist
natürlich ein ja ein erhebliches
finanzielle einschränkungen denn ich
habe mit seiner frau gesprochen die hier
einen souvenirladen betreibt natürlich
sagt 'mensch uns fehlen vor allen dingen
die ausländischen touristen gerade die
amerikaner wie hier beim watzmann der
man kann es ja im hintergrund sehen wie
toll dass hier alles aussieht also eine
malerische kulisse hier fehlen vor allem
das lebt sehr sehr sehr stark vom
tourismus gerade der ausländischen
touristen die dann auch hier gerade mal
so da ich mich hat sich sagen aber
überzeugte maßkrüge gekauft um sie dann
als zubehör mitzubringen und auch wie
gesagt die stornierung denn gerade in
den hotels die gehen jetzt hier zurück
bleibt abzuwarten was dann dieser ja
dieser lockte um bedeuten soll
wie das dann hier umgesetzt werden soll
denn ab 22 uhr gilt ja auch eine
sperrstunde wenn das jetzt noch weiter
reduziert wird ja dann gute nacht
berchtesgaden mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren